and welcome to hannity tonight again we
begin with a fox news alert first a new
poll shows
surprisingly shockingly even two-thirds
of americans want actor will smith
arrested after he slapped chris rock for
making a joke about his wife now this as
new video has just emerged showing smith
making fun of a bald person shaved head
several years ago we'll get to that in a
moment but yet we begin tonight with
another day
of the biden administration's attempt to
clean up joe's disastrous trip abroad
and it's not going well our current
president is a walking talking liability
to the country the world and its
seriousness in these times are
extraordinarily dangerous in case you're
keeping track while he was in europe joe
wrongly suggested that our uf soldiers
would soon be on the ground in ukraine
he forgot the name of his own secretary
of defense yet again and referred to him
as the secretary of state he spent
several hours choking if you recall on a
spicy pizza a piece of pizza he falsely
claimed that u.s soldiers were training
ukrainian forces in poland he said that
putin cannot remain in power which his
handlers had to clean up and say this is
not the position of his administration
and then guess what he pretty much said
the same thing yesterday now in a
monumental effort to right their ship
well biden staffers they think they're
clever they're now providing the
president of the united states with his
daily cheat sheets featuring one
sentence answers to the most simple the
most basic questions
in massive font about joe's own policies
and yesterday joe did his very best to
read see that little cue card there to
read from the sheets take a look
i want to make it clear i wasn't then
nor am i now articulating the policy
change i was expressing the moral
outrage that i feel and i make no
apologies you do feel that vladimir
putin should be remained from removed
from power is that what you're saying no
what i was i was expressing just what i
said i was expressing the more outrage i
felt towards this man i wasn't
articulating a policy change
good job joe he read it all by himself
he did he did good now ask yourself what
kind of president needs a note card to
answer a basic and predictable question
like this the truth is and i'll say it i
was right before the election joe biden
is not well he is not competent he is so
cognitively weak that his own staffers
won't let him or trying to stop him from
going off script which frankly i agree
with it is a necessary protection in
these perilous times almost everything
he says is poorly read from a
teleprompter or now these new note cards
almost all the questions that he's taken
by the media mob are preselected by
white house staffers and still despite
all of this assistance joe is struggling
worse than ever over the past couple of
weeks have been really really bad just a
quick reminder
a woman who just died the secretary of
state used to have an expression she
said we are the essential nation the
reason why i won the general when the
secretary of state asked me if i sent
another 12 000 troops along to the
united states i said yeah from the
united states
the first lady's husband uh contracting
covert but uh look at this room and what
you see
apart
that's right
she's fine
it's me
that's not together
the second lady the first gentleman from
mom to get her kid on the internet to be
able to do their homework has to pull
into mcdonald's parking lot
i mean for real
that's what's happening
this law is going to put an end to all
that
going to put people in a much different
position to be able to determine their
own
their own judgments about when to sell
their cattle
and a pound of ukrainian people the
proud proud people pound for pound ready
to fight with every inch of energy they
have
come on come on man are you a junkie um
or we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men and women he
said are created equal endowed by the oh
the the thing oh you know the thing god
the creator of everything now sadly at
this point it's not even shocking i have
been warning you about joe's obvious
cognitive decline since he came on the
scene to run for election and what we're
seeing is not new except
it appears to be getting progressively
and dramatically worse you decide
when
the political coverage
[Applause]
[Music]
that
look
um
some of the political
players and some of the
[Music]
let me ask you a rhetorical question
[Music]
[Applause]
this isn't funny according to a brand
new poll john mclaughlin nearly 60
percent of americans want both joe biden
and nancy pelosi to undergo cognitive
testing by the way kamala harris well
she's got her own train wrecks to deal
with now how many times has president
trump been on this program either on a
satellite in person or on the phone how
long how many times has he talked for 40
45 uninterrupted minutes he's always
very well informed
on any topic i bring up fully completely
engaged up to date energetic articulate
and smart as hell
i'll take the smart articulate guy that
is tough that the world fears uh
with the mean tweets i'll take him back
any day so would most americans by the
way look at this new poll harvard harris
poll trump is trouncing biden and harris
handily if the election were held today
meanwhile one recent nbc poll shows a
whopping 71 percent of americans they
are not confident about joe biden's
ability to manage this crisis in ukraine
the same poll found that biden's
approval ratings are now at an all-time
low with americans worried about record
high inflation a 40-year high record
high gas prices you've never paid more
and the instability abroad but high in
their ivory tower biden's protectors for
example over at msdnc
well they they just can't seem to grasp
why joe's poll numbers are so low why is
this happening take a look
charlie i want you to explain that to us
i just ran down some significant hard
evidence positives that we're
experiencing and biden can tout why
isn't he reaping the benefits in the
polls these are big wins
well because we are a politically
divided country and this is the united
states of anxiety
and not to be outdone so-called
journalists on fake news cnn don lemon
he had this to say about joe's disaster
of a trip to europe take a look
the president is saying exactly what
most of the world feels about vladimir
putin now he did not in that speech say
that vladimir putin should be removed or
we're going to take him out of power he
said this man should not remain in power
quite honestly i think this this is a
media manufactured story and the media
it's in the media's interpret
interpretation
oh a media manufactured crisis oh okay
according to fake news cnn no wonder
nobody watches that network now
meanwhile washed up nbc anchor tom
brokaw believes guess what fox news is
to blame for putin's hostile invasion of
ukraine the dog bite it's the bee stings
you're feeling sad blame trump if
there's an invasion by putin blame trump
take a look
from the beginning putin has been a
warmonger with a sour face he obviously
thought he could run over ukraine while
president biden was under constant act
by fox news and ever more poisonous
right-wing political organizations
uh tommy why didn't he do it when trump
was president and also i have a question
for you tom are you proud about all of
the lies all of the conspiracy theories
peddled by your nbc news about that
phony trump russia collusion that never
happened because your silence was
deafening and at the end of the day the
media mob you could try and protect joe
biden and pass the blame but we the
american people we're not dumb we're not
stupid uh we don't need giant no cards
to perform basic and simple tasks we
don't spend long weekends in delaware
recovering from the exhausting work week
of one
public event less than one a day we
don't need help remembering names dates
on a daily basis that is joe biden that
is your president he is clearly and
sadly not up to the job hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else